mes chers amis nous entamons la dernière
ligne droite pour l'élection d'une
nouvelle présidente ou d'un nouveau
président de notre famille politique
les républicains c'est une nouvelle page
que nous allons devoir écrire tous
ensemble nous les adhérents des
républiques et je dis bien tous ensemble
notre mouvement est riche de son
histoire de sa diversité de ses talents
et il a traversé les crises et les
défaites et chaque fois il a su les
surmonter
l'année 2010 est a été difficile pour
nous eh bien nous devons surmonter ce
que nous avons vécu je vais vous dire
que avant tout je souhaite je vous
demande de rester unie rassemblée
car rien ne serait plus terrible que des
divisions elles nous ont déjà tant coûté
je crois qu'ensemble nous pouvons
construire l'avenir des républicains je
crois en la force d'alternance crédible
que nous représentons alors les 10 et 17
décembre prochains
notre votre mobilisation est essentielle
il faut que nous soyons tous à ce rendez
vous le rendez vous d'une démocratie
interne vivante
un rendez vous qu'on peut pas rater
merci